creíamos saberlo todo sobre moler sin
embargo no se conservó ningún manuscrito
original de su obra y poco se sabe de su
vida las historias han cambiado con los
regímenes políticos la exposición
moliére la fábrica de una gloria
nacional pretende de construir el mito
para restablecer la verdad histórica
[Música]
al estudiar a molière su vida descubrí
que era un hombre hiperactivo que tenía
múltiples trabajos fue actor autor
director de compañía y también tapicero
del rey se dice que incluso antes de
morir estuvo a punto de fallecer por
fatiga y enfermedades
desde trajes de época reconstruidos
hasta máscaras de irak y fell realizadas
para la película poco la la colección
reúne cerca de 200 obras porque molière
no sólo es un tesoro nacional sino ton
en el dramaturgo francés más leído ha
representado y traducido del mundo
actual la exposición da un gran lugar a
las giras de los artistas franceses en
el extranjero hay un texto muy
conmovedor sobre una gira de jean billar
por áfrica en el que explica que
africanos y franceses pueden reconocerse
juntos en la misma referencia y es
también lo que es más interesante el
autor que ha sido re apropiado por
diferentes culturas y en particular por
las culturas que participaron durante
varios siglos en el proyecto de
colonización de francia y que finalmente
se quedó con molière para poder
explicarnos que este teatro que habla de
los matrimonios concertados que habla
del dominio de la religión sobre la
sociedad es de hecho también un teatro
para nuestro tiempo en diferentes
regiones del mundo y que sólo
remotamente se refiere a la sociedad
francesa del siglo 17
[Música]
en su época moliére era una estrella hoy
en día es una referencia indiscutible su
obra ha vivido por cuatro siglos de
historia y sigue tan vigente como
siempre